all right
tasha yeah tasha where'd you grow up
where are you from originally
what no south central kind of south
no it's the black part of uh
the ghetto yes it is yeah um
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
off and on i can remember just off and
on
different you know but it was never the
same one
you know i mean it was my father first
and the energy
as time progressed it was other men in
and out and things of that nature
so you had uh different dads your mom
had different yeah
we had different dads and stuff like
that and
yeah a lot of them too
how would you describe your childhood
it was sad i believe you know now that
i'm a joke
and i can think about certain things and
certain scenarios it was sad because i
don't feel like a child
should have to go to some of the things
i went to because
from my watching like animal programs
and things like that
and when you see like mama bears and
certain dogs and things like that
give birth and stuff they're very
overprotective and they'll do anything
and everything you know to protect
the young you know and i didn't get that
you know i mean i didn't understand that
then but when i think back on it it's
kind of sad
what kind of stuff happened to you
molestation
being chicken america um
been told that i'm i'm i'm lying in when
i was trying to
bring my truth but you know
when you 4 5 9 10 11
you don't have the maturity to
to explain or orchestrate a conversation
where
people can understand where you're
really coming from what really happened
you just know you was in pain and you
was in fear you know
stuff was really really hard and then i
was abducted once
by whom they couldn't find me nobody
knows to this day nobody knows
you know what i mean is how old were you
it said like four or five years old
you know me and i was tampered with
um and from that that
from that time on i could always
remember
being
took advantage of in some shape form or
fashion
if it wasn't physical it was mental you
know if it wasn't mental it was just
being isolated you know i mean so i
wouldn't be able to
tell people or say something or you know
i mean because these
things most of the things that were
happening to me was happening to me by
family members
and people that i knew you said i'm
saying
and back in those days i'm 58 years old
so back in them days even when things
horrible things like things like that
used to happen
it was a family thing you didn't take it
to the police
you can take it to school you know i
mean you just couldn't do it you know i
mean
they would keep you indoors for two or
three weeks to the healing or the black
eye or the
whatever kind of damage it was done to
you was down and
and life went on you know and how were
things
for you as a teenager they were a little
bit more interesting
because um
i noticed that i was real different i
just didn't know what i was
i thought i was the only one but my
looks
kind of um it sounds like i'm conceited
but no
but my looks kind of gave me um
a free pass for a lot of things you know
what i mean
and um and you're dressing as a
male or female background female i was
stressed out to female
back then because i wasn't either or you
know i i never was able to blend in and
be one
you know what i mean and like i said in
my looks
it helped it so when i did decide to
do the thing and i don't know what
possessed me to say you know i can do
this
it worked for me and i remember bumping
to a few other people later on down the
line
that were just like me but they weren't
so lucky when it came to that look
and you could tell specifically what
they were
me the problem i had you just couldn't
tell period
you mean but that came a problem became
a problem too
you know what i mean so um it was just
really really strange how things worked
out and then as i got
a little more older i became a little
bit more
manila manipulative you know i mean i
start to
well i can use this to my advantage you
can make money with it
not just make money just you know not
get too short in the stick all the time
you know something so i don't have to
tell nobody but i can make you believe
that i was gonna tell somebody
because i became arrogant and i started
to be a little louder
more voiceless and stuff like that and
you would do what i needed you to do
so the same thing they were doing to me
i was doing to them but just in a
different format
to serve my purpose you know what i mean
so the pain was a little less
you know it was like i don't know it was
just weird i don't know
what happened or what moment it was that
i just started
well if you don't do i'm gonna tell my
daddy or you know what i mean
but i just got this the spirit in me all
of a sudden
i'm not gonna let nobody take advantage
of me no more that's when i start
becoming physical with people
you know i mean and then i realized you
know i was because i was so tiny
yeah i mean i really didn't have that
much
return physical but i knew i could pick
something up
and when i would pick some up i would
get them together they gave me a sense
of power too
almost you know what i mean and then at
the same time you still was gonna give
me something afterwards
you know and that went on for years and
years and years you know
where is this taking you as an adult it
took me prison
it took me reform school kept me group
homes
family treatment programs it kept me
institutionalized until i was about
25 years of age it kept me
you know locked up in men awards and
um family treatment programs and
and i fought hard you know because by
this time i had a backbone
and then people started speaking out
on what i was because like i said in the
free world
nobody knew but when i was in these
institutions
they knew because of the name and i had
to be segregated with the guys
so forth so my problem became with them
now you know what i mean
and i thought long hard like how dare
you you know
i fought and fought so i stayed in
trouble in these institutions
i stayed in a hole i stayed in the four
points where they strapped me down i
stayed
um heavily medicated you know sedated
and
strapped down and
i don't know it was pretty weird how
things worked out
because no child asks for that kind of
stuff you know what i mean
all i was trying to do was um
make a [ __ ] up situation a little
lighter on me
and like i said i wasn't mature enough
to understand how to orchestrate that
but what i wasn't gonna do was i wasn't
just gonna lay down just take it
you know what i mean i just couldn't do
that
no more just be took advantage of be
told
sit over here or to be quiet and it got
to the point that i became so defiant
with everything then i became my worst
enemy you know
you know then i got into drug scene
and that's when things really really got
bad
you know what drugs were using back then
we used to do this
thing you called shrunk all species pop
pills
in my day then we used to do this thing
called lovely
it was a sweet almost like sherman but
we
we smoked that and then we would do the
um
the thing that's called crank but it was
a recreational thing back in my days
because
the world was different than you know
like fridays and saturdays and
sundays you know you run the streets
after hard days work or doing what
you're doing
you you little chew to your little party
you make a little money and stuff like
that and then
when money got back around life it
became
back to normal you know it didn't become
um a daily thing
until i said around the 90s
when it was a thing that you really knew
what addiction was
you know what i mean because now people
are consuming this stuff every day
and it's a need now so it wasn't just a
party favor
just to have a nice time at the club or
to dance or you know what i mean
to uh go out and turn some tricks and
stuff
you know and with that being said you
start to neglect
self so now you right back to where you
started
so the same thing that was happening to
you when you were young
you learned how to get out of it when
you became addicted
you started doing the same thing to
yourself
that these people were doing to your
life was doing to you
you mean so it's strange how things work
it's really strange i've always
that was just funny to me that's why i
always said you know i became my worst
enemy you know
because most of the things that i went
through in the last 10 15 years
that was really really horrible um i did
it to myself
and i did it eyes open and didn't give a
[ __ ]
you know i figured i've been through all
that you know whatever it's whatever you
know
because in my time you know you just
didn't live
past 18 19 transgender oh
no especially if they could tell you was
a boy
and a dress oh they found you in the
alley somewhere
and it was very very very frequent
when i was growing up down here in
hollywood long beach the valley and
stuff like that
it was very very frequent and then
around
i say like 90 to in the end of the 80s
and stuff like that
they started doing a silicone type of
treatment
so the ones that didn't have that
natural quality
they would enhance it with this silicone
and these hormones and things of that
nature
you know i mean and um even though they
still didn't quite look like a woman
because to me they look like science
projects today because
it doesn't look natural you can always
put your finger to it
you know even when they look nice you
like
you only went out at night time i mean
so they can cover up the flaws or the
mistakes that was made doing that
so it was kind of strange coming up
watching the transformation
so sex work became part of your life as
well it became part of my life but but
i i i became real perceptible i
watched everything because i didn't get
no schooling
you said i'm saying i left home at an
early age in these institutions and
stuff like that
so i paid attention to a lot of [ __ ] so
i memorized stuff
so everything i did mostly was by memory
you know what i mean
i just said you know when i seen these
people doing these
injections and going through they was
going through
i was just uncomfortable with their look
even if they they looking nice it was
just
i just always felt i don't want to be
like that a science project you know
and um i just stayed clear away from it
and unfortunately
you know like i said i just didn't have
the problem that most of them had
i never grew hair on my face i didn't
have to put on makeup to look like a
girl i just
just look like a girl and that was my
biggest thing in life i just want to
be either or if i could have been a boy
in the past
that had been fine with me too you know
what i'm saying but unfortunately
i blended better looking like a girl and
it served my purpose like i said
i was illiterate you know i mean i left
home when i was young
how far did you go to school i didn't
like i said when i was in third fourth
sixth grade stuff like that
i stayed in the office you know i mean
these um
classes for people slow learners and i
would just sit there and throw champions
and
fight with the teachers and fight with
the
students and stuff there so i really
didn't do the school thing
you know
so i put all my um energy into my look
at that time when i was young and my
look
took me a long ways you been in love
before
unfortunately yes i've been loved before
yeah love is kind of sad
to me because
men don't love the way women love and
when i say
the way women love i consider myself a
woman i don't see myself as transgender
trans transsexual none of that because i
came up in a different area i always who
i was
then later they started putting labels
on because you're only what you answer
to in life that's my belief
you mean i don't even when i worked the
streets i didn't
that they sucked my dick i didn't [ __ ]
them in your asses
you mean one had to be the dog and one
had to be the cat
it wasn't gonna be two cats and two you
just that just was my thing
i got off on the fact that i looked like
this i carried myself like this
and and i'm gonna be just that and i'm
not gonna compromise
i fought you long and hard because i
felt like i was pushed there
you know that was the only two that i
had to survive at that time
you know yeah
and it worked for me for a long time and
i got older and i got sick
you know i got real sad the brain
aneurysm and
the heart attack because i was born with
the heart murmur and stuff
and doing the crystal shooting dope and
stuff like that
and later on down in years you know when
you're not doing so well
and you look and your beauty is not
working or paying off like it used to
you know now i'm starting to feel like
everybody else
you know i pride myself on not being
like anybody but me you know
but now we're doing what everybody else
doing
[ __ ] up apartment why get some rent you
know what i mean get a chance you know
what i mean
go on a hut you know turning the trick
for twenty dollars when
i know i had alcohol problem i had a
drug problem
you got me twenty dollars twenty dollars
we're gonna buy you know
pack of cigarettes and a cisco and and
some drugs
how many of you do that that was
mathematically impossible
but i pride myself on i have always had
a boundary
i don't do what the normal people do
this in
certain situations such as this don't
get me wrong i'm not an angel
i'm not saying i've never done some
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
to um to get over
but it never made me feel good
so i made a firm decision even at an
early age
it's just certain things i just won't do
to justify
you know my happiness you know what i
mean i'm not gonna knock you beside your
head and check your wallet
so i can put some money in my pocket you
know what i mean i'm just not gonna do
it
i'm gonna work for it whatever we've
grown
that's what we're going to do and that's
what it's going to be i'm not going to
set you up
you know i'm not going to steal from a
girlfriend because she lets me
come in and sleep in our couch for three
days and while she's at work or doing
her thing
her husband come in and we in her bed
[ __ ] it's just certain things i just
wouldn't do
you know and today to this day i pride
myself on that because
i believed in all in all everything i've
been through in life i didn't let this
[ __ ]
completely take over
maybe i didn't become the complete demon
you know what i mean i just figured i
was a fallen angel
i had a boundary i always had a
conscious
and um and i found out that i was real
simple
when you lived to be my age and from
that time
life is really simple we make life
complicated
you mean by these this extra baggage we
pick up
we pick up all this different baggage i
mean we don't mean to do it at that time
but we don't know nothing
from here to there these are things that
we're learning but
we don't understand then when you get to
here
you can pick the baggage and now you
just develop all these different
characteristics and personalities and
desires and these different feelings and
emotions and stuff like that
but they're part of you now you can't be
like to just say oh you're jury
stricken that from the record the jury
ever hurt well what's been said you know
because you can't lie to self i don't
give [ __ ]
would nobody say like they say a drunk
you will never hear a drunk till a lie
everything come out a drunk smile this
is true
you know can't lie to self
what regrets do you have in your life
what regrets do you have
in your life
the biggest regret that i have in my
life is um
my mother because um
even though they didn't understand what
i was back here and stuff like that
my mother was for me everybody i grew up
with didn't have mothers and fathers
they was disarmed it was kicked out
you know i chose to leave you what i
mean
my mother was always there for me she i
could always knock on her door
when i would get on a farm and call her
i don't care what time or night it was
or dad was and i could be with several
other transactions in the whole chat
room
she would get up off her ass she would
come out there and bring the money to
pay the rent so we wouldn't have to be
out in the streets you know
and then she died on me you know and
that that's my biggest regret is she
died
and i was never ever to i was never
able to really like um
well this is the biggest regret is my
mom i know people have to die and stuff
like that but it's just like damn
i i could do no wrong in her eyes
and she knew i was a mess
she knew i was [ __ ] mess but she
understood because she was there from
the beginning you know
and she always was a mother to me first
she always was that she had her issues
you mean a lot of [ __ ] i picked up i
learned from her
and she don't even know it but that was
my mom you know
and she's always telling me i'm not
gonna be here forever and i'm like going
with all that old lady you know
and then she died it was like oh my god
you know me like who's gonna bury me
certainly not this [ __ ] that i think
i'm in love with you know me
i'm my so-called girlfriend you know i
mean did they only visit me if i'm
i'm in the hospital if they get an
operation who gonna bury me
you know who gonna say eulogy for me you
know
and so that's the thing that i'm going
through now these
these um thoughts of
trying to
accept things that i can and cannot
change and
just make the remaining years of my life
you know
not so difficult you know me because i
got something simple
and life is simple it's really simple
like someone was talking about my little
car that i had why would you get that
ugly car
it's the old car this is what i remember
growing up yummy
it runs like a [ __ ] spaceship
you know it's not a bmw it don't have
rims
it i don't need prada and gucci
you know me i've never been caught up
with the height
of my desires with the public likes
you know you surveyed surveys say this
is
this and just [ __ ] that i go down and
buy me a two dollar spin neck outfit
put it on give me some accessories and
put it together and look like a million
bucks
you know and i was more content with
that than the other [ __ ] put myself
out there trying to live like i'm the
joneses when i know i'm not
who am i lying to now you're really
overworking yourself
you know me and you don't get no rest
so if you don't get no rest you [ __ ]
up in the head mentally
you don't mean you're going all through
these issues you're going through
you know what i'm saying and then you
add that to the element it's just too
much you get exhausted
you get to be so exhausted sometimes
sometimes be so exhausted i just was
like
[ __ ] when can i rest
because i can never rest i have to do
everything and there's nothing wrong
with that but the thing
is i never had a break from it
you know everything has always been up
and running the rat race
you know would you consider yourself
happy
no i don't consider myself happy i
consider myself to be
a little bit more enlightened like
i believe i think i know what i want now
i don't know how to put it into words
but
i know what i don't want and i know what
i'm not going back to
that i know for a fact i'm just not
going back to it i'd rather be dead than
just go to just to live like that
anymore
or to be somebody's punk in a trunk or
you don't mean to be
used in and most of all i'm not going to
use myself
does that mean i'm angel no it doesn't i
still get high
i do it in moderation that don't make it
any better but
at least i'm more of aware and i have a
little bit more control
because like i said at once i just
didn't give a [ __ ]
especially after she died it was like
whatever is whatever anyway
i was supposed to live this long anyway
58 years old
who hurt it's unheard of you don't mean
it is unheard of it really is unheard of
oh it's unheard of and it blows me away
every day
every day i wake up i'll be like thank
you guys so much
thank you so much i don't know what it
is you see in me
but i got to be here for a reason you
have to have some favor
you know so when people start talking
[ __ ] and saying what they saying on the
lives
i was created by the father son and holy
spirit in there
and god has faith around me [ __ ] your
opinion
because that's just what it is an
opinion
for somebody that's trying to live their
life you know what i mean and that's a
sad thing that most people go through
life living out
living in life to other people or or
paying that much attention to somebody
else's life
life is short why do you [ __ ] about what
i'm doing
what my fetishes are what i like what i
dislike
you know you [ __ ] know me but you put
that much energy to me
into me like that it's a waste of time
it's just weird how people do that
what's the most important lesson you've
learned
you weep what you sow that's the most
important that's nothing i learned in
life
you weep what you sow i don't give a
[ __ ] what you do in life
whether you're aware of it you do it
intentionally or you just
do some [ __ ] because you're young you
don't know better
you're going to be put in this position
one day
maybe two or three times you'll know how
that [ __ ] feels
and it's not gonna feel pretty and then
when you feel that certain feeling it
can either do one or two things to you
it can make you evolve to the next level
where it'll make you
set a boundary about what you will and
won't do no more
or it could send you over the edge one
or the other
you know i mean some people just say
[ __ ] it
so you will with yourself yeah i bet
it's the most important lesson i learned
in life
you don't get away with [ __ ] nothing
ain't no such thing as a perfect crime
you mean you don't get away with nothing
if nobody ever find out in life till the
day you die you go to sleep
is he right it's right here you know i
mean you you can
you can't get away with it you know me
karma's a [ __ ]
yeah you can't get away with your mind
it's
when you look at that mirror it looks
right back at you
all right tasha thank you so much for
sharing your story oh hi
very interesting thank you thank you
very much all right
you